I'm garc Salona I'm the dean of The
Graduate School of Business I'm so
delighted to have this opportunity to
connect with our alumni we have put
together this video and the accompany
letter which will give you just the
taste of some of the key things we're
doing we find that the Mantra of the GSP
which of course is change lives change
organizations and change the world is
really resonating with young people who
are thinking about where to spend their
time at business school and the kinds of
students we're attracting really want to
make an impact really want to make a
difference in the world looking back I
think it's given me an ability to dream
bigger than ever before the best part of
Stanford is the great community of
people just the energy right when you're
around here it's really hard to put into
words but just everyone is starting a
company and and and you feed off of that
we've been working hard on
multi-disciplinary collaboration for a
number of years at the GSB and we're
continuing to do so know we think it's
extremely important because we think
that the really big problems in the
world are not addressed by just one
discipline it's amazing the sense of
collaboration here one of the best parts
has been working with students not just
at the GSB but also across campus
because there's so many big ideas that
are coming out of the students here at
Stanford startup garage which is L by
Professor zenios is a great example of a
course where we put students together in
teams from across the university so they
can share their expertise around a
startup project everyone brings
something new to the table in terms of
skill sets but they also bring a whole
different life perspective definitely a
life-changing experience another way
that we're continuing to build
multi-disciplinarity is through our
joint degrees we now have something like
20% of our MBA students taking more than
one degree at Stanford to that list of
current joint degrees we have just added
a new joint degree with computer science
and we're working on another one in
electrical engineering for the near
future we think that educational
technology is on the cusp of having a
very significant impact in higher
education and we want to be sure that
the Stanford Graduate School of Business
is in a leadership position one of the
things that we've invested in are a set
of Studios which are really sets in
which our faculty are able to produce
very high quality content the course is
strategic it's not a course for Human
Resources people but rather for high
level general managers none of this
technology at the moment is reducing
classroom time what it is doing is it's
enabling us to really use the classroom
time for those topics and that content
which is most engaging and most
interactive we are also using the
technology to increase our reach one of
the things we've been experimenting with
this year is offering executive programs
or other programs abroad by enabling our
faculty essentially to beam themselves
in from the night Management Center into
facilities abroad we've chosen to use
Stanford ignite as the key program with
which to have a presence around the
world our goal in experimenting with
this technology in this format was to
see if we could reproduce the classroom
experience at a distance and I think
we've achieved that through Stanford
ignite see the Stanford Institute for
innovation in developing economies is
now up and running and we opened our
first Innovation Center for seed in aana
there are companies in these regions who
have the potential to scale we believe
that those businesses when they grow can
provide employment can provide the
resources for the communities to pull
people out of poverty one of the keys to
making this work is that we have five
alumni who have have committed to being
on the ground for 6 months who will work
with these companies as coaches and
mentors to make sure that the content
that they learn from The Faculty is
translated into practice in their
companies the GSB alumni is a very
important part of what makes the GSB
what it is I want to thank you for all
the ways in which you do engage with us
whether it's in your reunion as a union
leader or a participant whether it's as
a chapter leader or volunteer whether
it's coming to the GSP and participating
in classes or in the executive challenge
there are a whole host of ways in which
our alumni engage with us and with our
students and we're extremely
appreciative of that
engagement I want you to engage with us
and to come and visit us we're also
coming to visit you we have a road show
that we call the business of change we
have already visited the Portland
Seattle and Chicago areas we'll be
visiting a variety of other cities in
the United States and abroad please look
out for a visit that's close to you and
come and spend some time with us where
you'll learn even more about what's
going on at the GSB
today